marvels what if comics have taken
readers into unexplored corners of the
Marvel Universe for decades and with a
Disney Plus animated series in the works
audiences will soon see some of these
intriguing scenarios explored on screen
here's a look at some of the most highly
anticipated options one of the most
thought-provoking issues of the what-if
comics series is what if Captain America
hadn't vanished during World War two in
that alternate reality Kaif and Bucky
continued their heroic adventures well
into the 1960s until Bucky takes up the
Stars and Stripes so Rogers can become
the first director of shield the thought
of cap and Bucky returning to fight
crime in a post-world War two America
has some very appealing Batman and Robin
esque vibes but the real draw is seeing
how those two might have interacted with
the various MCU characters of that era
having Steve Rogers visit Howard and
Maria stark in the hospital to
congratulate them on the birth of their
first son would be just one of a few
intriguing twists to the kids not even
here yet me there's nothing I wouldn't
do for
[Music]
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 revealed
that yondu originally abducted Peter
quill from Earth so he could return him
to his father ego the Living Planet
fortunately for the young space pirate
yondu grew attached to the lad raising
him to become a ravager had yondu made
good on his assignment and returned
quill to ego the MCU would have been
majorly affected
Figo would have been able to harness
quills ultra powerful energy to consume
the universe with the planetary seeds he
planted and he might have even achieved
his goal of galactic domination had egos
plan gone off without a hitch who could
have stopped it
we know quill was abducted in 1988 so
most of the current members of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes couldn't be around yet
Captain America would still be frozen
Tony Stark wouldn't be Iron Man yet and
Bruce Banner would still just be a
scientist however at least one potential
power could stand and he goes way
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers a member of
the intergalactic Kree force around the
time of quills abduction would be the
most logical first line of defense
getting to see the most powerful Avenger
battle a living planet sounds like just
the sort of thing
what if should be doing especially since
it's animated and can thus fall off
these sorts of big action scenes
speaking of yondu abducting young
earthlings
what if the blue alien had taken another
child entirely speaking to discussing
film
what if showrunner Ashley Bradley teased
an episode of the series featuring two
Chawla as star-lord we wanted to see
what if the worlds of Black Panther and
guardians of the galaxy collided it's
super exciting to work on because again
it's seeing these characters and seeing
the combination of character
interactions in this reality was to
chala taken as a child instead of Peter
quill leaving him to eventually become
star-lord and assemble the galaxy's
favorite ragtag crew of heroes if so
does that leave Cherie to rule Wakanda
as Queen as well as Black Panther how
would kill monger play into all of this
at the end of Thor the dark world Thor
is given the opportunity to take up his
birthright and become king of Asgard
instead he chooses to live on Midgard
with Jane Foster leaving the door open
for the reign of Loki impersonating Odin
this also leaves Thor free to assist the
Avengers on various missions before
heading back home
thor ragnarok how different would things
have been had Thor decided to rule
Asgard and protect the nine realms
instead for one you could argue that an
observant King Thor would have really
complicated thanasis plans in Avengers
infinity war Thor Groot and Rocket
traveled to Nitta Valier in hopes of
forging a new danos killing weapon only
to find it devastated by the mad Titan
and the real king of Asgard had been
watching this kind of planetary
destruction would have surely sparked
Asgard's involvement you could even
argue that many of the events if thor
ragnarok would have been entirely
avoided had a dutiful King been in
charge including the death of Odin and
subsequent return of hella Loki's rule
although brief had far-reaching
implications the Battle of New York was
the first time the original six Avengers
teamed up but the collaboration wasn't
exactly a smooth transition what would
have happened had one or two of the
heroes simply not been up to the task
every members contribution was crucial
to the victory and without the full team
assembled Loki and Chitauri could have
conceivably won what then since Loki was
working for Thanos the mad Titan could
have done to earth exactly what he did
to Kimora's home planet after wiping out
half of Earth's population he might have
even made good on his word and left Loki
in charge of the planet it would be
interesting to see what a decimated
earth would look like with Loki as king
which heroes would rise to challenge his
rule whatever happened to Emil Blonsky
aka abomination in the Incredible Hulk
aside from a throw away mentioned in an
episode of ABC's agents of shield the
souped-up marine turned monstrosity has
seemingly been on ice longer than
Captain America you have to wonder how a
character that powerful has existed in
the MCU for so long without making a
second appearance what if when
assembling his vision of the Avengers
Nick Fury decided to recruit abomination
for the team's muscle instead of the
Hulk
Blonsky sort of makes sense due to his
military background plus he's apparently
been in a special prison since the
events of the Incredible Hulk
whereas banner was a fugitive it would
have been a lot easier to recruit
someone who had a definite location with
a lot of training and an attitude
adjustment
Blonsky could have conceivably worked as
an Avenger after all it's not like the
team as opposed to ad
members who were initially foes like
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch Iron Man
nearly lost his life while trying to
defeat the Chitauri in the Avengers what
would the future of the MCU have looked
like head Tony Stark's Iron Man died in
the Battle of New York Stark certainly
left his mark on the Marvel Universe and
a lot of his contributions took place
after the Avengers so many things would
be different if the iron Avenger had
kicked the bucket early what Ultron
still have been invented
Howard Peter Parker spider-man have been
recruited to the team woody at all
perhaps most importantly who would have
sacrificed themselves to defeat Thanos
at the end of the vengers endgame the
MCU without Tony Stark would be a pretty
bleak place indeed in Captain America
Civil War Stark is tasked with bringing
in Captain America after an incident
involving a brainwashed Bucky Barnes
although stark and his team managed
capture caps compatriots rachis and
Barnes end up besting him and a final
friendship severing brawl in Siberia cap
then goes on to free Hawkeye ant-man
Scarlet Witch and the Falcon it's
interesting to wonder what would have
happened had Stark won the Siberians
showdown arresting Captain America and
potentially revenge killing Winter
Soldier for murdering his parents years
ago cap probably would have been sent to
prison with the rest of his team and
they would have conceivably been stuck
there until the events of infinity war
unless of course they managed to break
out Hulk chose to fly away in a Quinn
jet after the events of age of Ultron
leaving his friends behind
somehow he arrived on Sekar where he
became the Grand Master's champion until
he joined up with Thor in Thor Ragnarok
although Banner eventually returned to
earth a lot happened during his extended
leave of absence perhaps the most
notable conflict was the superhero Civil
War which pitted Captain America against
Iron Man what would have happened if the
Hulk had been around when that went down
during civil war Stark mentioned that he
wished banner was on earth assuming he
would take his side be gracious we had a
hope right about you and he shot
you really think he'd be on our side
despite Natasha's concerns it's not hard
to imagine Hulk siding with Iron Man
which could have drastically tilted the
scales toward team start seeing Hulk's
inclusion in civil war would have
undoubtedly made for an action-packed
episode of what if if you think Eric
kill monger is the best villain in the
MCU to date you aren't alone the Black
Panther baddie was a force to be
reckoned with
even besting T'Challa in combat and
claiming the wakandan throne fortunately
for the rest of the world the chawla
lived and was able to defeat his
long-lost cousin but what if he hadn't
kill mongers main plan was to send
advance to wakandan weaponry to groups
that would incite anarchy and overthrow
governments around the world
T'Challa and his allies just barely
managed to destroy the cargo ships
before they could reach their targets
but it's interesting to think about what
would have happened if they had failed
for starters this kind of widespread
attack on society would undoubtedly
catch the attention of the Avengers
although the team would still be divided
after the events of civil war it's easy
to imagine both squads putting their
differences aside to deal with kill
monger especially considering two
challahs solid relationships with both
Captain America and Iron Man if the
Avengers had attacked a kill monger led
Wakanda they'd surely be in for a tough
fight which would make for one
undeniably entertaining episode of
what-if earning the soulstone arguably
the most complex of the six Infinity
stones is a bit of a lose-lose scenario
in order to claim it you have to
sacrifice the thing you love most in
infinity war Thanos killed Gamora his
favorite daughter
on for mere as a means to add the gem to
his gauntlet in end games time heist
long time pals Black Widow and Hawkeye
travelled to the gloomy planets in the
past in order to claim a past version of
the stone although both tried to
sacrifice their own lives for the cause
it was ultimately Widow who made the
jump how would things have been
different had Black Widow lived and
Hawkeye died instead it would have been
tough for her to have to break the news
to Clint's family after Hulk snapped
them back into existence but her
presence means more to the future of the
Avengers after all she seemed
in charge of the team after Thanos has
snapped while Captain America led group
therapy sessions and Tony Stark started
a family with pepper how would the
future of the MCU changed if she had
lived
despite its slow decline in popularity
over the past few years AMC's The
Walking Dead is still firmly marching on
in the network schedule and the ratings
how would you feel about another zombie
show only this time it takes place in
the MCU it turns out Robert Kirkman
co-creator of The Walking Dead comic
book series also wrote a five-issue
miniseries about zombies and dating the
Marvel Universe in the early 2000s since
then the concept has been impossible to
put to rest
suit fans of the MCU have noticed that
if you look closely enough at the
what-if logo you can make out a
zombified Captain America hidden behind
the font this subtle clue led many to
believe that one episode of the animated
series would play with the Marvel
Zombies Comics storyline which takes
place on earth 21:49
in the Marvel multiverse that theory
turned out to be accurate as a preview
has confirmed that Dom bees will be
invading the MCU the only question is
how
perhaps Thanos whose primary goal
centered around population control might
choose a more creative way to eliminate
half of the universe's population by
snapping zombies into existence or given
the obvious supernatural theme of the
undead maybe a foe of Doctor Strange had
something to do with it regardless
hopefully Thor remembers the one
important rule when it comes to dealing
with zombies
[Music]
have gone for the head check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the Disney Plus
MCU shows are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you